you single by the way no oh you're not
i'm not well do you have any dating
advice from me because i'm single i've
been single i cannot believe you're
single so so single i am making a list i
want
oh i'm so good i'm like emma from the
austin i'm i'm a good matchmaker and i'm
on it
i i wasn't even asking for that but my
goodness so much it's my favorite
um
yeah i was single for a long time like
very purposefully yes you know needed a
long time like four years to transition
and honor and just do my own thing i got
to have a relationship with myself for
the first time i'm the mother of kids
and daughters so i it's all out there
but like in the last two years it is i
am fascinated with discussing how it is
to be single in this modern age yeah
well i mean the last two years was it's
not an easy time to be single and also
dating in new york like i've never i'm
english and the whole concept of dating
in america is so different over there
if you kiss someone in england you're
basically together like this whole i'm
dating a few people thing i'm like god
what is that like how does anybody
manage that like i must be british
you've got to go to england yes yes i am
i'm not a juggler no um if i met someone
on a dating app and we like said hello
i'm like oh we're together now and i
shouldn't
even talk to someone else on the dating
app because the guy who like owns it is
watching me yes and he'll know and i
can't do that
oh yeah yes then i'm gonna make it
i watched the bachelorette and i
couldn't believe
that she can be kissing all of them and
like that they i like how does that work
i feel the same way i'm like how can
you be like because as soon as i kiss
him when i'm in like that's it like i'm
like i'm projecting and we're it's going
far i did have a few years many years of
my life when i was young i would walk
into a place and i'd be like you grab
the tide kiss make out with and then bye
oh amazing
and now i am like hello i mean look at
the way i'm dressed does this not tell
you everything
i am like
i am so different now
you've still got it in you you just need
to come out with me and i'm going to
take you out in the town we're going to
fight
[Applause]
yeah we're doing it oh we know how to
have fun we've been doing it for years
let's do it and also english boys i
think are quite nice
well speaking of all things british is
it true that you uh love this candy
which one i mean yes probably it's uh
hold on it's oh thank you
yes i found out your favorite candy
brewski what have you done michael with
the yellow ribbon
it goes i feel like i'm a sort of like
bridal shower or something um yes i was
i got some good intel from haryana our
producer
and she said that this was your favorite
candy
this is
incr how did you get this in america oh
good oh good okay good they are
so delicious
[Applause]
i'm gonna have one
[Music]
you